bueno en primer lugar lo que van a
realizar es una rotación para añadir
nuevos astronautas a la estación
espacial internacional cada equis tiempo
se hacen estas rotaciones para no pasar
largos periodos de tiempo en el espacio
y ellos bueno concretamente van a
realizar diferentes experimentos
científicos por ejemplo van a testar la
tecnología de tissue chips' in space son
unos chips de tejido muy pequeños que
son como modelos de órganos humanos con
unos tipos de células que se comportan
de una forma similar a las que se
comportan las las células de nuestro
cuerpo es para ver su su comportamiento
en microgravedad también van a probar
una nueva tecnología de paneles solares
unos paneles solares que son enrollables
y por último van a estudiar pues como
responde el sistema inmunológico del
cuerpo humano en microgravedad porque es
una de las preocupaciones sobre todo de
cara a la exploración humana de del
espacio profundo y de marte en las
próximas décadas ahora jorge siempre
vemos estos lanzamientos pero no somos
conscientes muchas veces de lo complejo
de esto sé que hay detrás de todo
lo que hay en un lanzamiento y lo más
difícil para llevar a los humanos al
espacio
bueno es algo extraordinariamente
complejo ya lo he comentado previamente
nuestra compañera son
muchísimas semanas meses años de
entrenamiento y sobre todo desde un
punto de vista tecnológico
la apuesta fortísima de space export por
este tipo de cohetes este falcon 9 que
además es reutilizable es la primera vez
que se reutiliza este tipo de cohetes
para lanzar astronautas al espacio están
sentando las bases de la próxima
exploración tanto de la luna como más a
largo plazo de marte ahora cuando sería
el regreso de esta tripulación y cómo se
realizaría el regreso a la tierra supone
más riesgos que los despegues
y la verdad es que no hay ninguna de las
etapas que esté exenta de riesgo sí es
cierto que el lanzamiento es el momento
más crítico pero space ex ha alcanzado
una tasa de éxito tan alta que la verdad
es que nos da muchísima confianza tanto
a los que somos aficionados como a los
profesionales el regreso también es una
una etapa crítica pero de nuevo los
sistemas de spacex están están muy
probados y bueno se espera que sean en
torno a seis meses es el tiempo medio de
estancia en la estación espacial
internacional para tener otra vez estos
astronautas de vuelta en la tierra jorge
un gusto gracias por estar aquí con
nosotros su buen día